foreign
hi Victoria welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Kim thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
um so my husband and I need some advice
so we don't make a stupid decision here
um so my husband and I have a small town
home our monthly payment is so cheap it
is under a thousand dollars which is
crazy for Tampa Florida right now
um our town home is super basic it's a
two bedroom two and a half bath no
garage and our plan was to pay it off
um and we're so close to it we have
about fifty thousand dollars in savings
um and we owe about 112 000 in our home
if we put that money towards our home we
would owe about sixty thousand dollars
and we could easily tackle that in less
than two years
um the thing is though we had a baby a
few months ago and I work hybrid our
home feels too tight and I am afraid I
will not be able to buy another home if
the price goes higher right now
um so we could upgrade to a three
bedroom
in a garage and by selling our home
including all of our savings and
whatever money we make from this home
um towards this other option we have we
we would potentially put down 50 uh
percent
and our monthly payment would be about
300 more than what we pay right now in
our current home now my question is in
what circumstance it's okay to not pay
off your home at this point is it better
to just upgrade or
just like suck it up and stick around so
Victoria I've got a question I've got a
question before Dave answers the money
piece uh what makes the house feel
cramped with a newborn and I want you to
be specific I'm not picking on you I
want you to really tell me what makes it
feel cramped they're not that big yes so
I hope well it is a two bedroom uh in
um two and a half bath so
um right now in order for me to not quit
my job my mom will be with us to help
with the baby for about a year
um so she's she's still going to stay
with us for a few more months
um she takes up around yeah I feel like
okay now you got me on that one I didn't
see that one coming one room for her
baby to sing with us yeah
um they do stay with us in the bedroom
which
um it's it's fine right now and we don't
have a garage so literally like we walk
into the house I am literally here's the
answer here's the answer here's what
you're facing Victoria okay
at the end of your story
when you get to retirement you want to
have had a paid for house for many years
before you get there
and as a result of not having a house
payment a huge pile of money
okay that's that's that's where that's
what we're aiming at we're agreed on
that okay now the question is how do we
have a life
that's reasonable
and under control and still accomplish
having paid off the house early
and creating a big pile of money
in your 40s 50s and 60s right how old
are you
I'm 31. my husband okay so if you'd go
and move up in house it's not an evil
thing you're not doing anything wrong we
tell you not to take out a mortgage more
than a fourth of your take-home pay
household take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed and so if you sell
your home and you take the 50 000 and
you put enough down and the mortgage
that you take out meets those guidelines
you're perfectly fine now why do we tell
you those guidelines because we want you
to pay it off for your sake
okay but but it's okay to move up in
property and at your age with the idea
that we're going to turn around and
start paying it off as fast as we can
because the faster we get it paid off
the wealthier we're going to be
right so it's not like you need Dave's
permission to get a bigger house
anything to do with me
it's got to do with you need your give
yourself permission to get a bigger
house which is going to slow down your
wealth building a little bit because now
you've got a bigger mortgage to get paid
off before you get rich right
right but you're trading that for a
little better quality of life three
bedrooms and a garage and some stuff
like that and a place to Camp mom for a
little while she's probably not going to
be there forever though kid grows up
things move on right but um but but
still it's okay to move out of a two
bedroom no garage townhouse
in Tampa Florida you can probably afford
to make that move up with the large
equity in the down payment and all that
kind of stuff you're putting together
you're probably fine to do that but you
know it the the thing you don't want to
do is get in the mindset of most
Americans which is I'm just going to buy
whatever I want whenever I want
I'm gonna spend like I'm in Congress and
then I'm going to retire broke and hope
the government which is well known for
its ability to handle money will take
care of me
and see just don't don't drop over on
that side of the bucket because that's
where people drown right that's where
you get killed so you know the fact that
you're fretting about this is a very is
a positive because it makes you realize
you're not going to do it over and over
and over again because some people the
way they celebrate
um getting a raise is they go get a
bigger car payment it's what most people
are doing
you know and that's not you know so what
am I going to go further in debt well
that's dumber than crud because it takes
you exactly the wrong direction now in
her case she's not doing that that's not
what's going on so I think you're
perfectly fine to make that move but you
do whatever you want as long as you're
as long as you're couching it in the
concept of I want to get my house paid
off because the faster I get my house
paid off the wealthier I'm going to be
and the more generous I can be and the
more I can change my family tree and
those things are all tied together
mathematically it's arithmetic